mes tee-shirts
c'est un voyage extraordinaire auquel
les eaux se prépare à 18 ans il embarque
pour la première fois à bord d'un sous
marin
alors il emporte avec lui le strict
nécessaire
douche shampoing de quoi se laver et
surtout garder le moral
céline est la mieux à offrir qu'en cas
de blues mon amour non en cas de 12 pour
moi j'ai pas trop vous je vais attendre
un peu voilà cela fait six mois que le
jeune matelot attend ce moment
ce matin qu'il quitte sa caserne pour la
rade de toulon où l'attend l'équipage de
la perle
par exemple un des six sous-marins
d'attaqué français
[Musique]
quand d'autres ouvrent à l'âge où la
plupart des garçons comme lui passent
leur temps à draguer et aspirent à la
liberté
léo lui a décidé de s'enfermer avec 75
hommes dans 100 mètres carrés habitables
avant de partir ils font la chaîne
humaine pour charger les vivres
[Musique]
pendant ce temps léo lui cherche son lit
il n'a pas droit au coucher de standards
je sais que je m'occupe réputés comme
tous les petits nouveaux il va dormir
dans l'une des plus grandes pièces du
bateau la salle des torpilles c'est sa
chambre pour les quatre prochains mois
je vous présente mon lit je vais dormir
quand même comme lieu pour dormir vivre
bah oui mais il ya toujours pire que
nous dans le monde
moi j'ai toujours aimé dans des endroits
restreints moitié notre cavale ce que ça
quand j'étais petit donc ça me dérange
pas du tout d'être ici bon ça fait que
dormir à côté de missiles exocet ça fait
bizarre on se dit mais on a confiance
que c'est du matériel quand même qu'ils
aient cassé qui est solide donc du coup
on sait très bien qu'on risquerait plus
qu'elles ne sont pas moins faim
c'est pourquoi je sais pas trop
léo aura à peine le temps de tester son
matelas et voilà il est déjà attendu sur
le pont c'est le grand départ
c'est mon patron c'était qu'il a postées
reçu le matelot va encore passer
quelques heures en surface
[Musique]
non non ça va là c'est la partie plus la
plus pratique donc moi je suis à l'aise
vraiment avec eux tout ce qui est
pratique
donc ça a vraiment pas de souci tout va
bien le sous marin doit être remorqué
par un navire jusqu'à la sortie de la
rade
bon j'ai pas le mal de mer déjà au moins
c'est moins ça très beau c'est un lac
je suis content de partir depuis le
temps que je vais partir
parce que j'ai par le fort pour fodé way
et profond de vitesse et précipitation
fais gaffe attention
pourtant ça marche
écrasée entre le souverain est mort
quand je serai grand je prends l'accord
dans l'air ouais comme ans après
d'accord on a fait attendre la sortie du
bassin
voilà comment on va fausser un petit
passage tu la vois tu la compagnie est
évident que sa tante dans l'eau ouais tu
me retiens tu - tiendra au cas j'ai
passé un truc
[Musique]
pour cette première semaine de mission
les eaux et le reste de l'équipage vont
devoir abandonner leurs petites
habitudes
ils vont plonger quelque part en
méditerranée quelques jours pour
s'entraîner et tester le bateau
une semaine cruciale pour le commandant
jérôme colonna d'istria
à 38 ans c'est l'un des plus âgés à bord
vous aviez hâte de partir oui on était
impatients étaient impatients on est
impatient parce que c'est
un cheminement de longue haleine on a
récupéré le
le bateau à l'autre équipage il ya un
mois et demi bon a conduit une fois une
phase de peau de réparation d'entretien
donc à temps il faut que tout ça
converge et qu'on parte à la mer une
fois au large ils ne vont pas avoir trop
le temps d'en profiter
quelques minutes après la fermeture du
dernier sas il va y avoir un problème
central condescendance est ce que sera
le bâtiment 25 mètres en à ses poings
serrés +5 seriez temps chuté
la première chose à faire en plongée
c'est de vérifier l'étanchéité du navire
dans la salle des torpilles rien à
déclarer seulement les deux derniers
mois pendant lesquels le sous-marin
était en cale sèche
certaines réparations n'ont pas été bien
fait le job et oui ça peut arriver a
étrangement plus un tuyau relié au
moteur de secours s'est brisé la coque
du navire prend l'eau
c'est pas bien le film est salée jacques
ma mère allait s'inquiéter à chaque fois
que je pars en mer depuis dix ans elle
s'inquiétait encore plus âpre
quand il fit les fuites du bateau prend
l'eau
ça prend un petit peu l'eau parce qu'il
ya plein de trous dans la coque
forcément donc on est très vigilants aux
petites entrées d'eau donc on suit tout
ça notamment à la première prise de
plonger la re découverte du vote mais
très vite
l'inquiétude monte
la race a rempli la fuite est plus
importante que prévu 252 les premiers
tests sont alarmants l'eau s'infiltre à
travers les parois du sous marin au
rythme de 4 tonnes à l'heure en
plongeant plus bas il deviendrait
impossible de tout évacuer le commandant
décide finalement de faire machine
arrière et de retourner au port
de la contrarier
comment
dix huit balises rouges
pas question de prendre le moindre
risque les forces sous marines sont un
atout trop précieux
seulement deux mille hommes pour dix
navires c'est l'une des branches les
plus secrètes de l'armée française
d'un côté il ya les lanceurs d'engins
équipés de l'armé nucléaire
prêt à dégainer en cas de guerre
mondiale de l'autre les sous marins
d'attaqué comme celui de léo qui mènent
des missions de renseignement partout
dans le monde et sont aux avant postes
en cas de conflit
il faut dire que ses 2600 tonnes d'acier
abrite un outil technologique redoutable
à l'arrière la moitié du navire est
occupée par le moteur un réacteur
nucléaire
il produit autant d'énergie qu'une
centrale pour 30000 habitants
il gère l'oxygène à bord et
l'alimentation en eau potable à l'avant
à côté de la cafétéria la salle des
torpilles d'or leo est juste au dessus
là où ils travaillent
le centre de commandement
[Musique]
une semaine plus tard le sous-marin
réparer nous retrouvons le jeune matelot
il est huit heures du matin
il démarre sa première journée de boulot
sous l'eau y est entrée
mais j'étais recevait merci le jeune
homme originaire de poitiers a débarqué
dans la marine il ya six mois
attiré par le grand frisson son métier
pilote de sous marins
c'est demain nos centrales va j'y vais
pour sa première mission il va devoir
réaliser l'exercice de la baignoire
il s'agit de maintenir le navire stable
juste au dessous de la surface pour
offrir une bonne visibilité au périscope
15 m et ce n'est pas évident à peine les
commandes lâché le sous marin est déjà
remonté à l'aise je suis à 14 noeuds et
c'est juste pas inspiré sur l'instant
sur la quinzaine
monsieur main droite ces barrières c'est
à bart la science permet de gérer en
fête le soir comme ça et c'est plus pour
l'immersion en fait l'immersion ici là
bas aussi pour devenir pilote a besoin
du bac
léo d'ailleurs n'a qu'un ca fait du
cuisine en revanche il a subi trois mois
de formation intensive dans un
simulateur jeu réa de six maisons de
bach ici que je donne et ici la
différence à la conduite d'une voiture
j'ai pas le permis maintenant on plonge
et paris
la différence avec une voiture c'est que
sous l'eau les eaux a peu de chances de
heurter un autre navire merci au 16 mai
à quelques mètres de lui
cet homme avec le casque vissé sur les
oreilles veille au grain c'est le
responsable du sonar dans le jargon on
l'appelle l'oreille d'or
il est capable d'identifier des
centaines de sons aquatiques comme ces
cétacés qui peuple les profondeur en
méditerranée gars les cachalots
parfois il entend aussi des dauphins
ça l'est plus ici peu plus abouti
les ce matin rien de très palpitant à
l'horizon à sept km de là
il a juste repéré un navire de commerce
donc là on entend les lys
on entend il ya un rythme ça c est
risqué pas très belle beaucoup parcouru
10 d'automatismes en lumière qui serait
beaucoup plus prompt cela dit pas
question d'aller le couler en mission
l'enjeu c'est de repérer ses ennemis
sans se faire repérer
tu vas aller à l'opposé comment pour ça
le commandant va opérer une manoeuvre
radicale est très risqué le sous-marin
va remonter de 100 m en moins d'une
minute
alors tous équipe en cas d'avarié
ça va me mener
allez on y est plus 30 assiette plus 30
cela veut dire une inclinaison de 30
degrés dans l'aquarium du commandant ça
donne ça
[Musique]
au poste de commandement tout le monde
s'accroche
tandis qu'à la cafétaria c'est tout le
contraire
[Musique]
alors on est partis 200 m assiettes
moins 30
cette fois ils vont descendre à 300
mètres le maximum pour un sous marin
malgré la profondeur le corps ne ressens
pas du tout les effets de la pression ce
qui n'est pas le cas de ce petit tuyau
une bonne et de vidéos cette fois rien
de grave
en cafétaria aussi il va y avoir un peu
de dégâts un placard invisiblement était
mal fermée
au final tous s'en sortent indemnes et
[Musique]
oui messieurs vont payer ça s'est bien
passé
passez l'amusement il faut nettoyer et
léo comme les autres mais la main à la
pâte
car à bord d'un sous marin il y a des
règles de vie à respecter
à commencer par l'eau il a beau faire 25
degrés en permanence à bord il est
interdit d'en consommer plus de 20
litres par jour et par personne alors
dans la douche c3 pression de 30
secondes maximum
cela veut dire aussi une lessive toutes
les deux semaines
à table heureusement on peut boire autre
chose que de l'eau du soda du vin ou de
la bière
là encore 33 centilitres par jour et par
personne
si malgré ces contraintes
tous gardent le moral c'est grâce à un
homme julien le cuistot
ok quand le bateau penche lui ne rigole
pas du tout
dans sa cuisine minuscule avec ses fours
hors d'âge faire à manger ici est un
défi quotidien
sur les fours c'est comme si vous avez
la main dans le four
non seulement les petites puces ça donne
des brûlures comme ça d'une longue à ces
voix là ces voleurs de la journée le top
chef c'est ça du sous marin
c'est ça parce que c'est vrai que quand
on voit les grands reportages etc
top chef oui ces grandes cuisines sont
tout le matériel à disposition mais nous
aussi on n'a rien fait mais on doit
quand même nourrir 80 bonhomme dans
trois mètres carrés de service par repas
et à chaque fois c'est entrée plat
dessert
ce midi escalope milanaise haricots
verts sur chaque mission grâce à julien
les hommes prennent en moyenne 4 kg à
bord il est difficile de faire du sport
pour éliminer il n'y a guère que julien
qui transpire à force de faire les
allers retours entre sa cuisine et son
frigo juste en dessous
cette fois c'est donc ça c'est une
assiette qui va partir aux officiers
hauts commandants comment dans ce conte
hansel si on la soigne s
si le cuistot s'applique autant c'est
aussi parce qu'à la clé il y a pas mal
d'argent
les sous mariniers sont parmi les mieux
payés de l'armée française alors rares
sont ceux qui abandonnent après leur
première expérience on éduque les jeunes
qui arrivent
restent ceux qui ne s'en sort bien
aujourd'hui les eaux gagne 2100 euros
brut par mois logé nourri blanchi
au delà de l'argent lui qui n'a ni frère
ni soeur est surtout venu chercher si
une seconde famille ça s'appelle
l'intégration j'avais été relation
conflictuelle à l'époque avec mes
parents et puis même quand j'ai dû faire
un choix entre l'alarmé faut pas faire
un choix parce que je rentre toujours
quand même souvent les voit rouge comme
ça mais quand j'ai dû choisir entre
partir à la marine ou rester chez moi et
j'ai préféré partir tout de suite parce
que maintenant je sais que ça depuis que
c'est normal tout ça beaucoup mieux que
mes parents parce qu'ils sont fiers de
ce que fait et puis donc voilà
21h la nuit est tombée en surface pour
garder le même rythme sous l'eau les
langues du sous marin passe au rouge
certains travaillent encore
d'autres regardent un film en silence
on s'occupe pour oublier son isolement
les enfants sont quand même là à bord
avec moi vivre loin des siens
jérôme le commandant ce qui est habitué
pour qui c'est le plus dur on se pose
souvent cette question parce que c'est
pour les pouces qui reste avec les
enfants les problèmes à la maison ou est
ce que c'est pour le marin qui viendront
se retrouve avec son équipage sa
cohésion et dans son espace confiné où
quand il arrive à maîtriser
moi je pense que c'est plus dur pour
elle épouse à la maison ce que vous osez
dire non maintenant c'est parce qu'on
est d'accord là-dessus tweb le lien avec
la famille n'est pas rompues pour autant
[Musique]
depuis 12 ans al'approche des beaux
jours
emilie la femme du commandant voit
disparaître son mari qu'est ce qui va
vous manquer le plus
et câlins et toi pourtant quand il est
là tu lui en fais pas mille un cinquième
enquête plus d'accord ok et qu'elle
allait vise aussi un peu quand même
pour pallier à ces quatre longs mois
d'absence
emilie film régulièrement ses enfants
ces moments importants que leur papa va
rater ils les découvrir à son retour ou
garder bien toi je t'avais bien connue
car durant la mission
les milices ne peut envoyer qu'un
message par semaine à son mari un texte
sans photo préalablement lui par les
autorités militaires avant d'être
transmis au sous marin alors la règle
c'est de n'envoyer que des bonnes
nouvelles si on est trop négatif on sait
que ce sera sans principes le principe
qui prévaut c'est l'autocensure c'est à
dire on sait quoi dire comment le dire
il est enfermé dans une boîte de
conserve
si le moral n'est pas bon ça peut avoir
des conséquences
l'autre conséquence quoi ouais j'ai des
coups de cafard est-ce que ça
m'apportera quelque chose de lui dire
après le retour effectivement rien
n'empêche de faire du style ses
doléances et ça a été au prix de cette
patrouille
j'en peux plus j'en ai marre mais on
trie les papas sous l'eau il n'y a
malheureusement pas que de belles
histoires
le pire ennemi du sous mariniers et le
sous marin lui même il ya 20 ans lors
d'un entraînement en méditerranée un
incendie se déclenche à bord de
l'émeraude un modèle identique à celui
où travaillent les eaux et le commandant
dix membres d'équipage vont y laisser la
vie
[Musique]
au quatrième jour de mer les eaux et
anxieux personnes le commandant lui a
demandé de rester en salle des torpilles
qu'on appelle aussi tranche delta comme
tout le reste de l'équipage
il va être testé sur une simulation d'
alerte incendie
soudain un départ de feu est annoncée
dans la salle des torpilles son premier
réflexe est le bon donnez-le alerte
dégagement de fumée lequel des séries
dégagement de fumée dégagement de fumée
tranche delta dégagement de fumée local
dsm important deuxième bon réflexe faire
évacuer la zone
on a quelqu'un et cela très vite à un de
ses copains jean marie joue les blessés
on a quelqu'un tranche delta dans
pareille situation
avant de porter secours la règle c'est
d'abord de se brancher au circuit d'air
et d'enfiler son masque à oxygène
car le feu grignote rapidement la
moindre particule d'air de m'attendre à
l'étranger tant en un blessé sur rance
le quartier à vouloir sauver son copain
à tout prix léo oublie c'était crucial
dans la réalité il serait
automatiquement asphyxiés l'examinateur
le corrige aussitôt les au sort son
masque
mais il ne trouve pas où le brancher ses
quelques secondes d'hésitation lui sont
fatales c'est la fin de l'exercice pour
lui point chaud à droite
dix minutes plus tard l'un sans
dissimuler sera circonscrit bilan deux
blessés dont les eaux
heureusement ce ne sera pas éliminatoire
pour léo le masque peut masquer j'étais
en train de le mettre en
j'ai pas le temps de finir de mettre que
des mines est éliminé on va savoir ce
qu'un exercice en un peu quatre jours de
mer c'est quoi le première impression là
bas c'est c'est vraiment ce à quoi je
m'attendais après l'école mais c'est
vraiment bien j'étais content d'être à
300 m par exemple s'il n'y a pas
beaucoup de personnes qui vont à 300
mètres sous l'eau panne nous c'est une
fierté je suis super content d'être là
la pratique l'équipage est plus polluant
pour l'instant
communication du grand saut nous allons
faire surface au cinquième jour
d'entraînement
l'équipage de la perle retrouve l'air
pur quelques minutes seulement le temps
de nous déposer au large de toulon dans
quelques jours après leur dernier test
ils repartiront pour 120 jours
d'obscurité une mission dans une zone
secrète
c'est vrai savoir faire
en 2017 ces sommes ne seront plus les
seuls maîtres à bord après la
grande-bretagne la finlande et les états
unis la france sera la quatrième nation
au monde à intégrer des femmes dans ses
missions au fond des océans